jeanne monde je remercie le passé je
remercie le présent vous qui êtes tout
cela est bien sûr je remercie le futur
celui là c'est le deuxième est comme on
dit jamais deux sans trois je vous dis
au revoir et peut-être à bientôt
ce prix vient d'un pays qui respecte le
film chéri qui lutte pour son identité
culturelle me battre et à vos côtés je
vous remercie
merci merci
s'étrangle âge yeux de recevoir cette
récompense delà de la profession une
seule main sur le graphique français qui
m'a toujours leur édition à mama fiona
corp et charles ou leap gens si les
patients déments retrouvés ont trouvé
mes amis ce soir
avec pareil que moi
sur peu de changements
asseyez vous entrez dans une carrière
longue et chaotique il ya des hauts et
des bas mais en ce moment il faut que je
me préserve et que je m'épargne et 7
standing-ovation qui est la première de
ma carrière peu chez moi créer des
incidents déplorables
je suis très touché excusez moi mon
français est terrible et je ne suis pas
très doué pour les discours alors je
vous ai préparé ses trucs pour vous
bonne chose je vous remercie
je ne comprends pas vraiment le concept
des prix en général je déteste l'idée de
compétition
le seul contre lequel je me bats six
mois pour aller plus loin chaque fois
dans mon travail
personne n'est meilleur qu'un autre
nous sommes juste tous différents mais
je suis très honoré de recevoir ce
cadeau de la france parce que j'aime et
je respecte beaucoup votre pays un pays
qui donne la possibilité à l'art de
rester vivant
il ya certains donc on peut dire qu'on
les a connus en culottes courtes a tout
écrit j'ai écrit mais enfin je vais
imposer c'est un peu comme ici je pense
que c'est drôle
non non non on a fait des répétitions
l'a dit claude soit un peu rigolo oui là
je t'ai pas connu en culottes courtes
comme truffaut happy planet jean pierre
léaud ou à la castine que j'ai fait pour
toi j'étais en short tu m'as pas pu m'en
suis désolé mais de grosses moi sur mon
texte eu le temps plaisir la bouche et
il ya 20 ans meryl streep m'a remis un
césar
ce soir je crois que c'est moi qui vais
rougir mais de plaisir en lui remettant
ce césar
je vais essayer de donner ce discours ce
dont mon français hésitant d'écolière si
par inadvertance je prononce où je dis
quelque chose bizarre ou d'inepte ou du
vol hier je vous prie de blâmer
l'américaine en moi cela me rendra plus
intéressant peut-être qu l'âme boillon
que je suis en réalité hockey est fini
et je suis très honoré merci aux
vous m'avez donné sept grands donneurs
ces grands grand chose pour moi
d'abord parce que il faut dire que
franchement je gagne pas beaucoup de
prix
surtout chez moi alors merci la france
merci
bonsoir non tiens tiens à dire ça quand
j'ai appris par dominique besnehard
enfin que peut-être personne ne connaît
dans la salle si mon agent c'est mon ami
quand il m'a dit que j'allais avoir le
césar d'honneur
j'ai tout de suite foncé sur ma moto
j'ai couru vers le docteur zuccarelli le
docteur des assurances j'ai dit qu'est
ce que vous avez raconté
non mais c'est si grave que ça docteur
jeudi jeudi dites moi dites moi
sincèrement j'en ai plus pour longtemps
qua non que je le connais le coût du
césar d'honneur un dernier petit césar
pour la route hewitt
le cinéma français a toujours été une
grande source d'inspiration et de
plaisir pour moi et c'est avec une
réelle joie et une grande fierté que je
restais 2 reçoit c'est césar ce soir
c'est aussi une reconnaissance dont pays
qui maintient que personnellement parce
que mes parents vivent ici depuis 15 ans
j'aimerais aussi vous remercier pour
votre culture votre climat vos paysages
votre nourriture et vos vins de la
vallée de la loire
mais je voudrais remercier ma famille
pour l'amour le soutien deux éléments
indispensables pour se vivre dans ce
métier moveo est étrange merci encore
hélas
les
si vos commercy vautours à la france
merci après c'est bien là dit que je dis
je t'ai coyne de juin comme une pastèque
m et maintenant après ce discours
helmand je suis un but j'ai envie
vraiment détendre c'est de te donner à
toi césar est en bleu c'est tout mais
césar tout mais michel-ange jérôme et
bang gang
j'étais dans ce que tu fais pour lui
nombre as est-ce que je pète engraisser
tu participes à notre illuminations et
pour cela nous t'aimons et nous te
remercie bon anniversaire
j'aimerais que viennent ici céline
sciamma avec sa jeune équipe et je vais
vous confier
venez vite on est pressé
allez les films l'année son buteur
anthony king vous en prenez soir et vous
transmettez d'année en année d'accord on
y va
non seulement je suis sans voix en tant
que francophile cinéphile invétéré
je suis pas assis sur un fauteuil
roulant pour recevoir sais quel secret
le fait de recevoir ce césar demeure de
la part d'un pays qui respecte le cinéma
plus qu'aucun autre pays du monde
je suis je suis sans voix je ne peux que
vous dire merci serait assez vous
remercier césar est ancré profondément
de mon coeur il comme merci à propos
vive le cinéma
et